bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
votre émission culturelle kiosque tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 30
mars la galerie le corbusier de trappes
présente jusqu'au 13 avril prochain
l'exposition de gilles vuille as un
travail de personnalisation de onze
thèmes universels qu'il considère comme
ces choses importantes
jacques de givry président de
l'association des amis du grand parc de
versailles est en plateau pour nous
parler du projet de mary disparu il nous
présentera les nombreuses wash de
thierry bosquet présentée au musée
lambinet de versailles jusqu'au 10 avril
albertine trichons benoît rousseau
perrine l'orne et cécile orsoni du club
b 8 nous rejoindront dans quelques
instants avec une reviendront sur les
journées européennes des métiers d'art
et l'exposition qu'il présente à cette
occasion et je vous le disais la galerie
le corbusier présente jusqu'au 13 avril
prochain l'exposition de gilles vuille
as un travail de personnalisation de
onze thèmes universels qu'il considère
comme ces choses importantes
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude l'humilité le courage l'amour
le dont la transmission ou encore
l'erreur humaine des valeurs des idées
des concepts mais surtout des choses
importantes pour gilles vuille à ce
plasticien depuis 30 ans l'artiste
présente à la galerie le corbusier onze
thèmes à caractère universel une envie
déclenchée suite à son exposition mythe
en abyme
présenté en 2013 à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt gilles travaillait
sur les mythologies contemporaines et
les mythologies antiques et je crois que
dans les mythes dans ces systèmes dans
ces structures symbolique il y a des
choses qu'on retrouve de manière
universelle partout et les thèmes qu'il
développe ici sont issus je pense tout
ce qu'il a pu la prendre dans limite
pour rendre compte de ces concepts
gilles aiguillettes personnalise
l'universel
pour l'illustrer l'artiste travaille sur
trois formats différents
il dessine d'abord sur petit format aux
crayons de couleur et pastels pour
pouvoir image et sa pensée n'importe où
et après une fois qu'il rentre à
l'atelier il fait des travaux un peu
plus grand en format raisin 50 70 à
l'acrylique où il commence à mettre en
scène de manière un peu plus structuré
les petits dessins et après il fait des
grandes peintures qui fait d'abord un
dessin au fusain et ensuite il met des
couches d'acrylique qu'il superpose
dessus et un moment donné quand la
peinture lui paraît incarner qu'elle est
présente puisqu'il s'agit de personnages
donc comme si ses personnages étaient en
face de lui
eh bien ils les arrête l'artiste dévoile
une position personnelle sur onze sujets
humains et propose un questionnement à
celui qui regarde
pour gilles vuille as une oeuvre
plastique au delà de déclencher une
émotion doit provoquer la réflexion et
une annonce musical tout de suite samedi
2 avril 20h30 la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux vous offre un
concert spécial ou voix et chansons sont
les maîtres mots
au programme guité son timbre rocailleux
et ben mazué avec son flow saccadé on
écoute jeu
regardez tout est si parfait autour de
toi le silence dans ma solitude
ma chère et tendre amie
que tant d'autres fuient ma solitude
toi mon contrat à temps
ma solitude
ma chère et tendre
que tant d'autres fuient massot je ne
venais pas d'absents
c'est tout le bien que je me sois
recrutons élégant
faire tout pour que ça reste je ne
gagnerai pas d'absents
c'est tout le bien que je me sois dos
remplis mon élégance gens tout pour que
ça reste
vivant
et avec moi en plateau jacques de givry
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'association des amis du grand parc de
versailles et vous venez aujourd'hui
nous parler du projet que vous avez
monté autour de marly disparus qui fait
en ce moment l'objet d'une exposition au
musée lambinet de versailles un an
peut-être tout pour revenir sur cette
initiative pourquoi avoir souhaité
monter ce projet c'est une initiative
qui vient du d'une expérience préalable
c'est celle d'une exposition sur la vie
dans le grand parc au temps de louis xiv
et l'artiste qui avait fait ses oeuvres
a bien été inspirés de faire la suite
c'est-à-dire marly alors l'artiste en
question c'est thierry bosquet il s'agit
d'un ensemble de gouache pour cette
exposition réalisée par thierry bousquet
un mot peut-être de présentation alors
thierry bosc est un peintre belge c'est
un jeune homme qui aura 80 ans l'année
prochaine qui a produit près de 300
gouache sur l'ensemble château de
versailles disparu grand parent disparu
et marly disparu donc à lambiner on va
avoir 50 bosch on a 50 doit exposer sur
justement cette disparition d'un parc
extraordinaire et c'est à l'initiative
donc du baron alain guillaume qui
possèdent ces oeuvres qui était un
ambassadeur belge qui habite à saint nom
la bretèche et au maire de versailles va
faire plus exactement je dirais même
dans les deux cas
en tant que président du grand parc pour
une première série d'expositions puis
maintenant pour marly au musée lambinet
pour montrer effectivement une trilogie
qu'a fait thierry bosquet puisque ça
comprenez aussi versailles disparu qui a
fait l'objet d'un livre la vie dans le
grand parc aussi et puis maintenant un
livre aussi sur marly qui réunit toutes
les oeuvres les 116 oeuvre sur marly et
non pas les 50 seulement du musée
lambinet alors on va commenter justement
l'exposition qui est présentée
actuellement au musée lambinet suivant
les thématiques qui ont été respectées
un mot avant pour resituer donc le
château de marly-le-roi il a été
construit sous louis xiv en 779
pour ses amis disait-il c'était un peu
pour les privilégiés de la cour et il a
été détruit
sous napoléon 1er sous le premier empire
et donc il ne reste quasiment plus rien
oui alors il ya eu une belle aventure
pour ce château qui a été disons
magnifique aussi magnifique que
versailles il a même émarger au budget
plus que versailles à certains moments
en particulier vers 599 et ce château a
donc été construit entre en fait c'est
180 et 190 pour la construction même
ensuite tous les décors ont été faits
dans les années qui ont suivi dans ses
décors parce que justement c'est le
premier thème autour duquel s'articulent
l'exposition c'est vraiment le travail
sur les extérieurs et les fameux trompe
l'oeil du château de marier les fresques
qu'ils étaient dessinés sur toutes ses
parois des bâtiments des bâtiments si le
pavillon du roy lé pavillon royal et
puis les douze pavillons pour les
invités alors on dit que c'était par
souci d'économie justement ce travail en
trompe l'oeil est ce que c'est le cas
c'est un peu vrai mais c'est surtout
parce qu'on voulait changer assez
souvent les décors c'était un petit peu
issus des fêtes à versailles l'idée de
faire des décors facilement
interchangeables et tout changer sans
arrêt dans le parc de marly en fait donc
ce travail de trompe l'oeil il a été
initialement dirigées par charles le
brun puis repris ensuite le deuxième
partie de l'exposition s'articule autour
du travail de l'eau qui a été fait à
marley alors on peut dire que versailles
était en disette d'eau par contre est ce
justement à marly où vous avez une
surabondance y avait des fontaines qui
jaillissait absolument partout il fait
qu'effectivement c'était pas le petit
ruisseau de marly qui il suffisait comme
au début mais la machine fameuse machine
de marly qui apportait 6000 mètres cubes
d'eau par jour qui permettait de faire
jouer les fontaines et en particulier la
fameuse rivière
qui sur 300 mètres de long avec tous est
en marche un an avec un dénivelé de 30
mètres dans marché mans marbre voyez
l'eau s'écoulait depuis le château
c'était un spectacle magnifique qui
impressionné évidemment toute la course
en 3 bat sans d'ailleurs de marbre rouge
pour rien absolument
et puis il y avait une quarantaine de
bassin au tout autour de répartie dans
le parc et c'était le plus grands jets
d'eau d'europe et même pendant longtemps
ça a été plus lent des jets d'eau
puisqu'il monte à près de 40 mètres
d'altitude dénivelé grâce à la machine
de ma vie un vrai modèle européen
on dit qu'à la mort de louis xiv il n'y
avait pas moins de 400 jardinier qui
travaillent et justement pour le parent
que de mal et alors au delà du travail
sur l'eau et des fontaines également des
sculptures c'était un peu un musée de la
sculpture
c'était un musée qui possédait une
quarantaine de d'antiques c'est à dire
des des statuts qui et où des groupes
qui étaient venus de rome enfin qui
avait été pris là-bas acheter bien
entendu ensuite il y a eu des plombs et
il ya eu des bronzes et puis la
troisième mode ça a été de revenir a dû
quelque chose de plus moderne des marbre
sculpté par oiseau par coustous etc dont
les fameuses zones marly qui ont
remplacé deux groupes sculptés et qui
était de quoi ce veau et qui se trouve
maintenant place de la concorde côte
études reee il y a des les grands
groupes qu'istres deux oiseaux et de
l'autre côté il ya les chevaux cabrés de
cousteau d'autres cultures peuvent être
admirées au au louvre est donc la
troisième grande grande thématique de
l'exposition elle se situe sur les
loisirs à marly qui étaient très
présents parce qu'il y avait différents
jeux justement qui
était situé dans le parc il y avait
cette fameuse escarpolette qui était une
forme de balançoire la ramasse une sorte
de deux montagnes russes
en fait c'était un traîneau qui glissait
sur des rails en bois sur une pente
il y avait huit places dessus et puis on
espérait qu'il ait pas d'accident à
l'arrivée 40 m de dénivelé plus bas sur
une grande allée et les 50 privilégiés
qui était invité à marly qu'avait
demandé cyr marly qui essayait d'obtenir
une place à marly évidemment tableau
promotion politique de se faire inviter
à marly totalement c'était en tout cas
le signe qu'on était dans les faveurs du
roi qu'il fallait il fallait y être
invité et y être vue sur tout donc cette
exposition elle court au musée lambinet
jusqu'au 10 avril
parce que derrière on peut imaginer
quelques perspectives justement de cette
volonté de faire revivre marly-le-roi et
bien le travail de thierry bosquet donne
envie de refaire sur le dans le parc de
marly faire revivre un petit peu les
cette vision par différents moyens
modernes on peut arriver à montrer ce
qu'était marly de différentes façons
dans le parc
peut-être par des constructions
peut-être aussi par des visions plus
multimédia que l'on peut imaginer
merci jacques de givry d'être venu en
plateau et de nous avoir présenté cette
très belle exposition que vous pouvez
retrouver au musée lambinet de
versailles jusqu'au 10 avril prochain et
tout de suite une autre information
comédie musicale 40 jeunes de 17 à 24
ans de l'association nantes la jeunesse
présente la création d'une comédie
musicale le dérange il
deux heures trente de spectacle un
spectacle original et dérangeant qui
allie la foi chrétienne avec les récuser
les expressions les plus contemporains
quatre représentations sont programmées
dans le 78 le dimanche 3 avril 16h30 au
chesnay en l'église notre dame de la
résurrection deux amantes les 16 et 17
avril prochain et une derrière ce sera
dimanche 8 mai
rambouillet tout de suite une autre
exposition il s'agit de celle de nuances
de noir présentée jusqu'au 24 avril
prochain à la galerie à l'écu de france
de viroflay 122 oeuvre combine le
travail autour des variations de
matières et de lumière de la couleur
noire image signée patrick jacques de
dixmude dès qu'on n'est pas trop
sculpteur on joue beaucoup avec les
matériaux donc toujours des effets louis
thomas dust artistes viroflay gyan
propose neuf sculptures en mardon pour
l'exposition nuances de noir une
exposition autour des variations de
matière de jeux de lumière ou de
mouvements de toutes les nuances de noir
l'idée elle est née suite à deux
expositions qui ont lieu autour du
leblanc et donc il a été question
effectivement de travailler autour du
noir autour de cette exposition et a
présenté une multitude de nyon ce en
jouant notamment avec un certain nombre
de techniques et de matières différentes
neuf artistes ont été sélectionnés pour
l'exposition 122 oeuvre au total qui
allie travail autour de la gravure du
fusain du marbre du papier de l'ardoisé
ou encore des plastiques et du bitume
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre la
lumière sur le noir ont montré que la
lumière est complètement transformé par
parler par le noir et par les
différentes matières et donc du coup
voilà de découvrir le mystère du noir
l'élégance la subtilité et sa luminosité
l'exposition nuances de noir et
présentée à la galerie de l'écu de
france de viroflay jusqu'au 24 avril
prochain et on reste à nouveau dans
l'univers des expositions cette fois ci
c'est la galerie du ruisseau d'elancourt
qui présente jusqu'au 24 avril
l'exposition dit déco miyata l'artiste
travaille des sculptures en pierre et en
papier
les sculptures en papier venant habillé
l'espace vertical laissées vierges par
les sculptures en pierre une proposition
pour mettre en perspective la solidité
de la pierre par opposition à
l'éphémérité du papier mais toujours
cette correspondance dans le travail des
vides
des pleins et de toutes ces aspérités il
découvre appel ce travail pape et
papyrus culte elle est dénommée enfin la
technique est là les dénomme sa papier
sculpter un effectivement on voit bien
que c'est pas un collage on pense bien
sûr on va le découpage mais on finit par
ne plus voir le découpage temps
effectivement le papier paraît sculpté
et aborder finalement comme un élément
utile à une troisième dimension
il ya 20 ans premièrement exposition
personnelle stade et roger paul emplir
au sol mais la mur c'est vide
son manager réalité de cette sorte de
travaille sur le paquet et vient de me
rejoindre en plateau albertine trichons
benoît rousseau cécile orsoni et périls
l'orme du club et vite
bonsoir à vous quatre benoît peut-être
un mot justement pour nous présenter ce
club invite alors le club et 8 oui c'est
une association qui a 7 ans et qui se
situe maintenant qui a pour objet de
mettre en commun des espaces pour les
artistes essentiellement mais aussi pour
des artisans d'art et puis d'autres
professions et voilà on est sur
l'aérodrome de saint cyr à l'entrée
voilà dans un hangar qui est réhabilité
et par ailleurs bon on va pas y rester
très longtemps puisqu'il ya des projets
immobiliers dessus donc j'en profite
pour fo voilà pour lancer un appel si
par hasard vous avez des regards là on a
à peu près de 500 mètres carrés on est
une quinzaine d'artistes à partager le
lieu est et voilà on va propos va
profiter de ces journées européennes et
métiers d'art pour montrer les
savoir-faire qui sont à l'intérieur de
l'atelier
alors justement la transition est toute
trouvée donc à l'occasion de cette 10e
édition des journées européennes des
métiers d'art vous présenter une
exposition que vous avez nommés la plus
grave
cécile peut-être un mot pour resituer
que sont ces journées européennes des
métiers d'art les journées européennes
de buts c'est dans ces deux jours
un présente un petit peu tous les
métiers d'art la gravure la reliure
enfin et c'est un nous on est plasticien
est donc là on organise une expo et sont
deux gravures voilà on veut montrer un
petit peu toutes les étapes de la
gravure comment on va creuser la plaque
comme on va en créer comment on va
imprimer tintin et je pense que c'est
important aujourd'hui de parler des
métiers d'art et de montrer ce que sont
les métiers là parce que c'est c'est un
mois 1 c'est un travail qui est blanc et
c est bon voilà ça serait plus sur la
gravure on va revenir sur le thème de
cette exposition que vous avez intitulé
la plus grave
alors pourquoi ce thème la plus grave
c'est à la fois un jeu de mot entre la
gravité le poids et la légèreté qui est
un peu le thème de l'installation
globale et donc à cette opposition être
graves ou légers etc
le chat peut se faire aussi en référence
au mot anglais pour live peut-être
quelque part puisque la gravure à moitié
morte mais la plus grave celle ci
directement via la gravure toit sont
donc vous allez être quatre artistes
graveurs à à participer à cette
exposition notamment vous donc albertine
très chaud comment est ce que vous allez
prendre part à ces réalisations
alors moi je suis artiste peintre déjà
et j'ai ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
justement de découvrir une nouvelle
technique donc pour l'occasion je me
suis mise à la gravure grâce à
l'invitation de cécile orsoni et donc on
va
tous de tous les quatre avec différentes
techniques donc technique de taille
douce qui sont la gravure sur zinc
cuivre et la gravure la taille d'epargne
ce qu'on n'a pas la taille d'epargne
c'est-à-dire gravure sur bois
linogravure moi personnellement je ferai
la linogravure nous allons procéder à de
vent donc aux visiteurs à des
impressions de co2 sera en temps réel en
ce temps réellement tout à fait sur bois
sur cuivre sur un sur lino en temps réel
voile devant les gens vraiment pour
montrer illustrer le processus de
fabrication de la gravure
tout à fait il y aura de toute façon une
exposition de nos oeuvres de plasticiens
et de graveurs déjà en parallèle en par
adacore venons est-ce que vous parlez de
performance je sais que ce mormon
contrarie mais non ça me contrarie pas
anodin le fait de travailler en public
ce n'est pas une performance en soi mais
peut-être que samedi soir si vous venez
au vernissage effectivement peut-être
qu'on aura l'occasion d'essayer une
performance avec perrine de l'homme qui
est témoin alors justement cette
performance vous êtes écrivain perrine
et vous allez travailler justement par
rapport au support à ce que eux vont
réaliser
voilà c'est ça en fait ce qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est le silence et
les bruits la gravure c'est un monde de
silence est aussi un monde de bruit ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de essayer de
rendre
oui je dirais le chant du monde qui sont
en train de créer
pour rendre ça plus palpable l'intérêt
en fait c'est sa performance c'est un
regard ce que j'écris à partir de leurs
oeuvres c'est un regard
je sais que par exemple c'est s'il
engage beaucoup son corps dans son
travail elle y va physiquement
donc pour moi c'est une wii c'est ce
serait ça essayer de rendre à la fois le
résultat mais aussi le travail en train
de se faire voilà aussi bien la chose
finit que la chose dans son élaboration
ces textes le soir à partir de 18 heures
le samedi
les taxes et leur a écrit pendant la
journée devant les offres qu'elle
qu'elle choisira en fait ce sera donc
les vendredi 1er samedi 2 et dimanche 3
avril à l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école
pour retrouver le club de beb 8 et
l'exposition la plus grave merci à vous
quatre d'avoir été invité mais je vous
en prie en plateau et donc n'hésitez pas
à venir les retrouver ce week-end à
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école je vous
invite maintenant à découvrir une autre
expérience sensorielle étonnante samedi
2 avril 15h et 16h30 au théâtre albert
camus de moore pas pour le spectacle
pleine lune le spectateur entre les yeux
bandés dans une salle plongée dans
l'obscurité
il est placé au centre d'un dispositif
électroacoustique olfactif et tactile
pour entendre l'invisible juliette
plions co créatrice du spectacle nous en
dit plus puisque la vue n'est plus l'aps
que la vue est absente et bien les
autres sens vont prendre le relais
donc il va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
sons de musiques tout autour d'eux qui
son spatialisé à différents endroits et
il y aura également des odeurs et des
sensations tactiles qui vont leur être
proposées et à partir de toutes ses
sensations et chacun va composer son
petit tableau imaginaire son cinéma
intime en fait nous on propose en fait
c'est comme la traversée d'une nuit on
va passer de la du crépuscule à l'aurore
notre propos vraiment c'est de montrer à
quel point quand on ne voit pas à quel
point on entend différemment il ya
quelques fois à quel point on perçoit
différemment
et l'on poursuit comme sec mercredi avec
notre rubrique cinéma tout de suite vos
réactions aux nouveautés à la fiche de
ce mercredi
pas tout à fait comme le livre d'olivier
adam est bon on y retrouve quand même
l'essentiel j'ai retrouvé aussi toute
une ambiance où toute hâte de se faire
et non puis j'aime beaucoup sa belle car
et franchement et qu'il tous les acteurs
japonais aussi été parfaite alors je
dirais mysticisme delà de la mort et
surtout de la vie de très beaux paysages
au japon certainement il ya très peu de
touristes
c'est à ces magnifiques et puis pudeur
et impudeur d'isabelle carré qui jouent
un très bon rôle est toujours en cinéma
l'udc vaud quand cette semaine du ciné 7
d'elancourt nous donne son coup de coeur
de professionnels sur le film the
revenant tu vois mon coup de coeur cette
semaine c'est imminente avec leonardo
dicaprio donc qui a été comme vous le
savez oscarisé à 42 ans enfin pour ce
rôle donc c'est un film d'aventuré on me
dira un grand film d'aventurés faut
peut-être bien que les avis sont très
partagés sur ce film ya des gens qui
aiment beaucoup comme moi et d'autres
qui aiment pas du tout pour moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé donc je vais vous en parlé
brièvement
donc c'est un grand film d'aventurés qui
se passe dans les années 1800 entre 1800
et 1900 je crois dans le grand nord
canadien
donc c'est l'histoire d'un chasseur en
fait qui est aussi au début
quand on dirige rapporte des points
qu'ils vont chercher dans les
territoires appartenant aux indiens qui
va un jour lors d'une chasse ce faire on
va dire attrapé par à un ours
enfin une maman ours alors cette scène
d'ailleurs est absolument terrifiante de
réalisme et qui va être laissé pour mort
en fait par ses compagnons mais qui va
survivre et qui va survivre notamment
pour se venger c'est aussi l'histoire
d'une vengeance sur la personne qui l'a
abandonné c'est un grand film pour moi
très très fort ça dure deux ans 38 moi
j'ai pas bougé de mon siège pendant deux
heures 38
les paysages sont sublimement film et on
a même parfois presque l'impression de
sentir les odeurs tellement c'est c'est
bien fait et je vous encourage vraiment
aller le voir alors par contre je
décourage des enfants à les voir parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de celles qui
sont extrêmement violente quand même
c'est très naturaliste c'est très bien
documenté c'est très bien fait donc
n'hésitez pas à venir le voir
il est encore sur nos écrans il le sera
encore la semaine prochaine voilà et
pour ce week-end quelques idées sorties
vendredi 1er avril 20h30 ils seront à la
batterie de guyancourt général elektriks
pour vous livrer les derniers sont de
leur opus aux mélodies pop et électro
soul
et pour fêter la 59e année du groupe
théâtral aux unionistes ils crient leur
54ème spectacle le mandat il est
question d'amour de pouvoir et de
politique
en 1924 à moscou représentations les
vendredi 1er et 8 avril 21h samedis 2 et
9 avril 21h toujours et dimanches 3 et
10 avril à 15 heures à la salle dunoyer
de ségonzac 14 de viroflay et enfin
mardi et mercredi soir 5 et 6 avril
20h30 au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines retrouver
pierre y gardant l'oeil pierre rigal
dans le spectacle érection érection et
l'histoire absurde et tragique de
l'évolution de l'homme à partir de la
position couchée pierre égale cherche
lentement mais sûrement à se mettre
debout dans les limites de son
environnement
et c'est la fin de ce que ce que votre
émission culturelle à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet
on se quitte avec de la danse sur un
extrait du spectacle justement de pierre
rigal érection je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée